my dad am I dead  the training I had was three weeks of  training every single day and you learn  how to literally change how you  distribute the oxygen in your body what  was that what do you think it was  I don't know it could have been 6 10 it  could have been 7 10. it was 7 15.  it's a very detailed quite extraordinary  process and I loved it and got really  really good at it you beat Tom Cruise's  record I know it's very funny people  keep telling me that but I want to know  how long he really actually held his  breath for because if it was six minutes  and something Sigourney actually also be  right his record I'm  so at one with the water in the space  you know you just don't want to be kind  of going like this or appearing to be  stressed because motion capturing you  can see absolutely everything